well I'm joined now by the sun's Royal
photographer Arthur Edwards political
journalist Ava Santina and talk TV
presenter Richard Tice Arthur great to
have you uh I really I thought of you
actually very soon after I heard this
news because it hit me hard when I was
took a phone call from someone a friend
of of uh the new king now in his Queen
console who just said the queen has
passed and it was before it was it had
been announced or confirmed and I felt a
real you know like a someone to punched
me and I remember quite quickly thinking
I wonder how you were because you've
been such a huge part of covering the
lives of the Royals and in particular
this queen
how did you feel when you how did you
hear the news Well I heard the news on
the BB on the BBC I think and but um I
was at up at Dumfries house with a
prince the night before and a part he
had a dinner there and um you know it
was a jovial it was a great evening and
then the following day I just saw
everybody clear out the hotel quickly so
there was and it was then I knew that
something had happened and then of
course when we got the news it was yeah
I felt for the prince actually because
like you were saying it's difficult for
him trying to cope with the loss of his
mother I mean your mother's your best
friend right okay who you are in this
world your mother's your best and he
just lost his father and he just lost
his father but now then he was then he
had to go and put a brave face on
everywhere I was and I just think he's
had a brilliant job and that speech he
made and I think he's made a great start
I totally agree with the King and I
think he's been incredibly moved and
encouraged by the warmth of the reaction
from the public because he must have
been slightly wondering once his mother
died this unbelievably popular Monarch
the greatest in my view in history he
must have been just wondering I wonder
how the public will react to me but the
answer has been with enormous warmth and
I think that's really helped him through
what has been a professional difficult
period where he's got to become this new
model but also personally when he's
grief stricken we saw Princess Anne in
the car behind the hearse yesterday for
a few hours looking completely anguished
yeah and you understand why she lost
both her parents yes so is King Charles
and yet we're expecting him to just get
out there and be the king I mean I
couldn't even imagine being that strong
actually in that situation well I mean
he always said you know history will
judge me and now he's come out now as
the king and people were seeing him from
for the many years the man I've been
working with what is he like he's a
fantastic person he knows everybody in
the world he knows every prime minister
every head of state he's so well
connected and he's and he's just
traveled the world I mean we were
Miranda in June with all the heads of
government there and they all paid great
homage to him I remember one person kept
down on their knees before him when he
came in there from Papua New Guinea and
and you know he is I just
the reason I still work peers is because
I work with this man and and the queen a
new Queen Camilla they're just fabulous
people and really that's really nice oh
yeah I just I really enjoy it if I got a
job with with with say the prince I had
John the king the next job which here
will be
um probably
um on Wednesday when they follow the
coffee
I will look to him but he will be solid
well you had an amazing little moment
with him uh after his mother died after
the queen passed and it was captured by
a photographer and you had just a short
exchange with him but tell me what he
said to you well he came off the plane
and uh I was the only photographer that
that the RAF lady took that
and um he just came up to me and he said
you're okay and I said yes sir I said
I'm very sorry about your loss and he
said well it had to happen someday I
think yeah it happened one day he said
yeah and I and then he just packed me on
the arm and you're okay and he and he
went off I mean Arthur what a moment for
you yeah and for him because he he
recognized that you would probably be
feeling very upset about this but for
you to have the new king of this country
actually inquiring as to how you're
feeling and having that exchange with
you is a remarkable thing for anybody
yeah but on the Wednesday night at the
party we were laughing together you know
we were joking together this there was
like you know 24 hours later there he is
we're sort of
it's it's coping and he's not worried
he's worried about me and I just
you know I said fine
but he was over I was a bit overcome by
it and are you surprised after that I
mean if you go back it was 25 years last
week since Diner's death yeah and if you
remember as I know you do but if the
people watching the art in the aftermath
of that a lot of hostility towards
Charles and Camilla who many people
blame for the breakup of the marriage I
never thought it was as straightforward
as at all
um but here we are now 25 years later
they've been married for 17 years it's
extraordinary to me to watch their
pathway back to public popularity in the
way that it's gone and and very
encouraging well just do it for hard
work you know put the head down and got
on with it certainly the the new Queen I
was going to say The Duchess but Camilla
she just put everything into it she took
only over 200 patronages and she's she's
just tirelessly as well but the most
important thing is she supports the
prince like for instance when they got
off the plane at Northolt the other day
he came down and she stayed back in the
cabin until we meet might be the station
commander and then she came down you
know and she's like she's done it all
the way she's never ever uh hugged the
Limelight in fact
um I just she is just perfect for him I
think Camilla's great well the queen
console yeah her correct title and in
fact I saw a BBC instruction earlier
that you should stop talking about the
late queen as the queen because actually
Camilla is now automatically Queen
console and that should be a title for
her and these things are important I've
known uh the queen console a long time
and got to know quite well actually and
sat next to her at dinner parties and
things like that she's an incredibly
down to earth decent woman she never
lost a common touch she never did no and
she's never she she has that effortless
uh sense of non-entitlement which the
queen has in a sense you never feel like
she feels she's entitled to any of this
you know she loved this man and if you
think about it in a way it was it's been
one of the great love stories it's
endured everything absolutely and
there's no doubt to me that Camilla has
made him happier than anybody else
absolutely and subtle and calm and much
more calm about approaching things yeah
you know he's he's a little bit of a
Sparky temper you know I'm not saying in
that for a long while no I mean not for
a long while and I mean I've had some
serious
telling off to him you know but you have
you've also had some great moments art
and I want to play you one this is from
2018 where Charles gives his views on
you
see it's a very good photographer and a
jolly good bloke I think and a very
special person and none of our overseas
visits I can assure this something would
be the same without arthrit was there
and I get more and more worried because
he's a bit further advanced than we are
and I always worried about the number of
cameras and bits of equipment that he
carries in boiling hot countries
so anywhere else I'm so grateful to for
for all your kindness today
I mean that's a pretty remarkable that
man's the king of this country now you
know paying that tribute yeah that
chokes me up a bit when he said yeah
because I mean I only expect that I made
a little speech in welcome to this was
his 70th birthday party we held to him
at the Spencer house and uh I welcomed
him and I talked about you know it
wasn't always like this you know it was
there were times when it was a little
bit hostile you know when Kelvin was the
editor and uh but you know what happened
I started to see what this man was doing
and I and I listened to his speeches I
was there when he when he was begging
the uh the for the president of Brazil
to stop ripping up the rainforest and if
he thinks he's got away with it now I
don't think Prince Charles is going to
give up he'll be giving the Prime
Minister a little bit of his mind about
that you know about the environment he
he probably won't be able to say
anything publicly but he certainly won't
give up